foreign
Georgia and talk to the mighty Trevor
what's up Trevor
hey how's it going Dr John doing good my
man what's up
uh so my main question here is how do I
ReDiscover my identity and gain
confidence and who I am so I can create
a more peaceful life for my wife and
myself
where'd your identity go
I don't know I lost it along the way
somewhere take me back on the journey
where'd you lose it so I wrote down a
little context you can spot me at any
point
um so I've always been like a dream
chaser really satisfied for the quote
normal lifestyle
but over the last five years or so I've
been putting on this Persona to try and
become this badass of a man I thought I
really wanted it to come end up you know
hardening my heart getting really into
self-development
um
I guess it was because that wasn't ever
the kind of person I was I was just like
sensitive hipster music type guy
but Fitness kind of brought me out of a
a dark time
into self-development with that became a
trainer but the story really starts when
I ended up in the Navy SEAL pipeline in
2019.
um because that was like the image I
wanted to become
but I ended up dropping through medical
discharge but it's tough to admit but
I'm gotten to a point where I can't
admit it I was really just dropping out
I quit yeah
um it's hard dude it's hard but go ahead
go ahead yeah
so it was a pretty rough experience
process just getting out of the Navy
that's that's a whole other story
um but and I got home just in time for
covid so
that started and then I became a
firefighter shortly after that it was
about three or four months after getting
back
so I didn't really have enough time to
really mentally recover
um because it shattered my ego like all
my hope you know and who I thought I was
becoming just all kind of got shattered
and I just kind of
muscled my way through recruit school
with the fire department and uh I was
there for
a few years before I ended up leaving
that let me let me just you know yeah
who told you
there's there's a running ticker tape
you know what that is like when you
watch the news that little Stock Market
ticker that runs underneath it just all
the time
yeah so running ticker tape in your life
under the story of your life
that says this guy sucks
who wrote that because you didn't write
that somebody gave that to you
who wrote that
which which time
um I think the biggest one was in Navy
in the Navy separations units you were
way before that
because here's the thing I have sat
personally
and hung out with Jocko and we've talked
about what guitars we play
so playing music and lifting weights
aren't mutually exclusive
being in the Navy Seals and me being a
dean of students man the first thing
Furthest Thing from being an ABCO good
grief man
those aren't mutually exclusive
that's not the issue here
you think you suck and I want to know
where that story came from
because you chased it with hipster and
clothes and you chased it with music and
then you chased it with muscles and then
you chased it with
um David Goggins fantasies and then you
chased it with fire jumping fantasies
you're running from something what are
you running from
foreign
I mean I was the youngest of three three
boys and
you know they were really hard on me
growing up I don't know if that's that's
it
I mean we could probably talk for hours
and unpack it here's the deal
like you're not a piece of crap man
and my promise to you is this one
thousand percent if you were in I know
this because I'm friends with them
if you were a Navy SEAL right now
you still would not like Trevor
period
if you and you fantasize about this if
at one of the fire fights you were
involved with if you saw a baby and you
raced in there and got the baby out
because I know you've played that out in
your head before
you would feel good for a minute then
the next day you would not like Trevor
the crappiest thing about accomplishment
as you go with you
yeah
and the crappiest thing about failure is
you go with you right yeah
so what like let's take the Navy SEAL
experience right
most people wash out because it's
designed for most people to wash out
and as someone who benefits from having
Elite military force out there fighting
on my behalf
a guy they don't even know
I hope most people wash out
I want those who don't to be you know I
mean
I remember spending some time with Jocko
and I was like
kind of my thing is like everybody's a
like we're all the same down to the core
right and then I remember about half
hour in I was like oh no we're different
we're different right and so I want that
I'm happy for that
and what about that experience washing
out weren't you able to go all right man
I found my limit I found the end and
that's awesome I know most men go their
whole life and they never know where
that end is
they never know what they're capable of
and they never know how how far they can
push themselves you found out
so what about that wasn't a celebration
of course you wanted to be a seal and
there's some disappointment there but
what about going all right I found
I train as hard as I could and this is
how fast I can run a mile I know I now I
know why why is that
I guess it confirmed what I was trying
to disprove in myself that you were some
kind of loser
yeah
where does that story come from
I don't really know
all right so what are you doing now
so I'm in pest control but the next part
of the story is I'm running an online
coaching business and I'm on my last
week full-time job because I've gotten
to a point where I can take it full time
so that's I'm really trying to dial in
I'm gonna say something really hard
right now and you're not gonna like it
is that fair cool yeah
well let me ask it instead of saying it
do you have somebody who is running so
hard for themselves do you have any
business coaching other people
do I have what any business coaching
other people right now
I mean I'm having some success of course
you are because you know all the right
things to say you're a real smart guy
and you've watched all the videos
yeah that's that's definitely a thought
I've had
let me answer the question I'm calling
well let me answer the question for you
if you don't quit on Trevor the answer
is yes
this last book I wrote about anxiety I
ended up leaving my family for a week
and I went to a hotel and checked in and
had to write myself out and I spent time
in the hotel gym and in front of a
computer 24 hours a day for a week
I went crazy
but I never gave up on myself I didn't
give up on my wife I didn't give up on
my kids
I didn't give up on my community or my
friends or my job I kept going and
sometimes it was one tiny tiny little
step in front of the other but I didn't
quit and so did that disqualify me from
for helping people with emotional mental
health no
because I'm I'm on the same path as
everybody else is in fact it I think it
gives me some empathy and it gives me
some understanding when somebody calls
you and says hey man I don't know which
way to turn you can go dude I know
but you sound like you are dangerously
close to quitting on Trevor
I don't know I feel like this is my
break to really
you know reel it in
I need you to hear me say the world
needs more coaches men need to have
coaches in their life
and
this will not solve you
yeah this won't heal you it's probably a
better word
if you get a million dollars worth of
clients this year
in your take-home salary is six hundred
and eighty thousand dollars after taxes
it will not heal you
your dad's not going to magically pick
up the phone and finally say he's proud
of you your older brothers are going to
finally say you know what dude we were
pretty hard on you as a kid you're
awesome
if that call hasn't come yet that Call's
not coming
and if it does come only after financial
success it won't feel right
what you have to choose to do is to love
and honor Trevor now
as you enter into this space
so what are what are the steps to do
that
I I don't know you quote unquote
ReDiscover your identity I think you
plant a flag in the ground and then you
reverse engineer it with a bunch of tiny
little actions
and so what do I mean by that you don't
I
Alex hermosi was here the other day here
at the at the studios and I think he's
the one who who first said this
um
confidence you can't think your way to
confidence you can't just imagine like
I'm gonna be confident I can fight that
guy because your body knows no you can't
or the first the first jab what remember
that Michael Mike Tyson quote
everybody's got a plan to get hit in the
mouth and you're like oh all right yep
that's not confidence that's arrogance
that's that's that's bullheadedness
that's Idiocracy
confidence is
I've trained for five years I've been in
a lot of hard sparring matches
I'm good
I can stand in here
right that's confident and so you get
confidence by a thousand little wins
and in your case you get confidence by
I'm going to show up for Trevor
not I'm going to show up for Instagram
muscles
and not I'm going to have the best
well-lit coaching photos so I can
encourage other men to get other
well-knit coaching photos and you've
taken them haven't you yes you have
yeah
and I'm not going to sign up from some
other world-class
like
12 people or however many few get
through the system a year
and I'm gonna hate myself that I wasn't
one of the 12. yeah be disappointed man
you went for it
most people are so such cowards they
never go for it
they never go for it you did
it doesn't mean you quit
and I'll say this
I think David Goggins is fun I think the
world needs David Goggins that is not a
recipe for a long healthy life
okay
I have chosen
whether it makes me a week week or a
coward or whatever
that one of the hardest paths you can
take
is to every day be a present father
to Everyday show up in the boring and
mundane and be a present husband
and
to do that to take care of my body and
exercise and to get enough sleep and to
get off my stupid phone all those things
that you know in the self-development
space but you got to ask yourself why
for the Instagram photo because you
think it's going to heal you because
it's not
it has to be because Trevor's worth it
yeah that makes sense I'm gonna ask you
to do something I just asked another
caller to do that my therapist asked me
to do and it freaked me out
all right
I want you to take your hand and open it
as wide as you can
and put it right in the middle of your
chest
okay
all right did you just Flex just now
when you did that I'm just kidding but
you probably did yeah I know you did I
knew you did I knew it
all right I want you to say out loud
I love this guy
say it one more time
I love this guy is it true
yeah
how do you love Trevor every day
foreign
just keep going
keep taking steps forward
I'll ask you again because I hope you
realize how terrible that answer was
yeah I do how do you love Trevor every
day
um
I appreciate his good qualities I don't
know I'm bad at this all right I'm gonna
give you a couple of things
here's how I appreciate John deloney
okay
I write down some things that I'm
grateful for
almost every day of my life
what that helps me do is realize I am
just surrounded by blessing even when
things are sideways and hard
I touch my daughter I hold her face when
she lets me
and I look her in the eyes and I let her
know
I'm so grateful that of all the crazy
people in the world God pick me to be
your dad
and you are really really strong
and you are brilliant and you're
beautiful
and she goes
and this morning I came out and my son
was already writing his book because his
parents are nerds and he was working on
something and I started barking at him
about the dogs and the chickens and the
this and what about that and come on man
what about this and then he opened up
somebody sent me some cereal to try out
for a sponsorship and it looked amazing
and I said hey you try this out first
and he opened it up and the bag went
everywhere just exploded
and I looked at him and I made a face
that I shouldn't have made just I was
disappointed like what are you doing
like anyway
he walked back inside
and I said hey I need to start over the
morning can we start over
and he goes what can we start over and
he goes yes
and I wouldn't give him a big hug and I
held it too long and I said good morning
I love you good it's good to see you
and then I went down and worked out and
I did not want to work out today I don't
feel good my recovery was 44. I didn't
feel like it but I went anyway
and then I showed up to work on time
prepared
and I could go on and on that's what I'm
telling you okay
do I want to look good and have muscles
yes
don't my wife just still think I'm
attractive yes am I ever going to be a
Navy SEAL no
do I hang out with a few of them because
it makes me feel cool absolutely yes 100
percent
100 percent
will ever be that no
is that the is that my calling in life
no it's not and I I made peace with that
a long time ago
but making peace does not mean quitting
Making Peace means a love Trevor
okay
so let's start with those few things who
do I want to be
I want to be a dad who's a good guy
I want to be a husband who shows up and
he's present I want to be a great small
business owner which is what you're
going to be doing when you're coaching
full-time
cool I'm gonna reverse engineer that
what do I need to do every day
my my identity becomes a series of
actions what do I need to do every day
to become a great present husband
what do I need to do every day to be a
great present dad
what I need to do today to be a great
small business owner show it for my
clients
start there wouldn't be a great
Community member a great member of my
church a great like fill in the blank
but start there do those things
and what you're going to find is when
you show up for yourself when you do the
things that you told yourself you were
gonna do
that's confidence
confidence is well earned
because at the end of the day you trust
Trevor when all else fails
Trevor said he was going to work out for
30 days in a row even if it was just
walking around the block Trevor worked
out for 30 years in a row because Trevor
trusts Trevor
that's confidence
confidence is a is a huge Foundation of
made up of a bunch of little bricks of
you doing what you said you were going
to do
and you can look behind you and you got
the proof
you can't think your way to confidence
you can't will your what you can't
manifest confidence you gotta go do
I wish it was different man I wish it
was different we tried it with a
self-esteem movement utter failure
doesn't work
you have to go do but you also got to do
from a place of I've got value and I'm
worth doing it
and you my brother are
hang on the line I'm going to send you
my book also building a non-anxious life
I want you to read it
um I want you and your wife to read it I
want you to go through it together I
think it'll make a big uh big impact on
your life
and by the way congratulations for going
through the uh
Navy SEAL tryout process
most men live quiet lives of desperation
you at least went for it I'm proud of
you